>> Tucker: WE BROUGHT YOU
SAD NEWS ON THIS PROGRAM A
COUPLE OF TIMES HOW MANY
AMERICAN STIPULATES SEEM TO
RESEMBLE SLUMS.
YOU MAY HAVE TROUBLE
VISUALIZING WHAT THAT MEANS
AND THIS IS FOR YOU.
AFTER LAST NIGHT’S PROGRAM
WE WERE SENT THIS PICTURE BY
A VIEWER WHO LIVES AND WORKS
IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
IT SHOWS THE SIDEWALK
OUTSIDE HIS OFFICE LITTERED
WITH BY OUR COUNT MORE THAN
30 SYRINGES AND OTHER DRUG
PARAPHERNALIA.
THIS IS NOT IN SOME
ABANDONED LOT OR FREEWAY
OVERPASS.
IT’S RIGHT OUTSIDE THE
OFFICES OF SPOTIFY, A TOP
TECH COMPANY IN DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO.
IT’S RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM WE WORK AND ONE BLOCK
AWAY FROM ZEN REZ AND
TWITTER AND UBER.
SOME OF THE RICHEST
COMPANIES AND RICHEST CITY
IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES WORK IN A
CIRCUS OF TRASH AND DRUGS.
THE QUESTION IS DO ELITES
EVEN CARE?
AND THE ANSWER IS NO THEY
DON’T.
U.S. CITIES AREN’T JUST
PLAGUED BY HOMELESS DRUG
ADDICTS BUT DEADLY CENTRAL
AMERICAN GANGS.
IT’S NOT PROPAGANDA.
IT’S REAL.
NEW NUMBERS OUT ABOUT THE
EXTENT OF MS-13 THAT’S THE
PRIMARILY EL SALVADORIAN
GANG BECOME THE DEADLIEST
ORGANIZED CRIME RING IN THE
COUNTRY:  JESSICA JOINS US
WITH THOSE NUMBERS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> I’M GLAD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: SO MS-13,
DESPITE, IT SOUNDS LIKE,
EFFORTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS METASTASIZING,
IS THAT WHAT THE NUMBERS
SHOW.
>> IT IS.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ATTENTION TO THIS GANG, BUT
IT HAS REBUILT ITSELF.
IT’S NOT A HOMEGROWN GANG.
IT WAS FORMINGD BY PEOPLE
WHO CAME FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA DECADES AGO
ILLEGALLY.
SO THAT WAS A FAILURE IN
BORDER SECURITY.
BUT, ICE AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WERE
ABLE TO STIFLE IT FOR A
WHILE THERE.
BUT IN RECENT YEARS, IT’S
REALLY REBOUNDED BECAUSE OF
THIS -- IT TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THIS SURGE OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS THAT’S BEEN GOING ON
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND ALSO
THE LACK OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
SO THEY HAVE COME BACK WITH
A VENGEANCE AND THIS IS NOT
JUST PETTY GANG VIOLENCE,
NUISANCE CRIMES.
WE’RE TALKING MURDERS.
HUNDREDS OF MURDERS THAT
MS-13 MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED FOR.
AND IT’S A SCOURGE IN A
NUMBER.
>> Tucker: IT HAS SPREAD.
TELL US WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE.
>> AT A CERTAIN POINT IN
TIME, THE GANG DECIDED TO
ALMOST OPEN UP FRANCHISES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
PLACES LIKE LONG ISLAND,
BOSTON, CHARLOTTE, NORTH
CAROLINA.
AS YOU SAID THE SUBURBS OF
WASHINGTON, D.C. BECAUSE
THIS IS A GANG THAT’S
CONTROLLED FROM EL SALVADOR
AND THE CLICKS IN THE UNITED
STATES DO SEND MONEY BACK TO
EL SALVADOR TO HELP SUPPORT
THE WHOLE GANG.
AT CERTAIN POINT IN TIME THE
LEADERS PUT PRESSURE ON
UNITED STATES TO KICK IT UP
A NOTCH AND START DOING MORE
AND BRING IN MORE PEOPLE
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
RECRUIT MORE FROM THESE KIDS
WHO RECENTLY ARRIVED.
THEY DO EXTORTION, HOME
INVASIONS, SEX TRAFFICKING,
PROSTITUTION.
AND MURDER TO PROVE
THEMSELVES TO EACH OTHER AND
INTIMIDATE OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND WE FOUND THAT THEY WERE
ACTIVE IN 22 STATES JUST IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND
CONCENTRATED AS I SAID IN
THOSE AREAS THAT EXPERIENCED
A LOT OF THE ILLEGAL
ARRIVALS FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> IT’S URBAN, IT’S RURAL AS
WELL AND SOME PLACES THAT
HAVE NEVER HAD THESE -- THIS
KIND OF A GANG PRESENCE
BEFORE.
AND IT’S DIFFICULT FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: WE SHOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE VICTIMS ARE
ALMOST.
>> SANCTUARY.
>> Tucker: VICTIMS ARE
ALMOST ALL IMMIGRANTS.
SOMETHING THAT IMGRANT RIGHT
ADVOCATES IGNORE.